[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
el 24 hoy dedicamos este espacio al arte
contemporáneo al encuentro del universo
de dos artistas el cubano español jorge
luis miranda carracedo y el francés
móvil reno masón más de 70 obras que
bajo el título cosmogonía se exhiben por
primera vez y lo hacen en una de las
joyas arquitectónicas de parís el
espacio niemeyer y tenemos en nuestros
estudios a uno de los artistas a
carracedo muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros los lotes y también tenemos
al comisario de esta exposición el
también cubano ros mi porter bienvenido
a ross mit son rosalba bueno ya antes de
ponernos de bien a explorar esta
fantástica exposición vamos a dar
algunos datos para situar un poco a los
oyentes y telespectadores
carracedo nació en la habana estudio en
la prestigiosa escuela de bellas artes
de san alejandro y en el año 2000 decide
salir a ver mundo y se instala en en
españa' y desaparece del circuito
comercial artístico cubano se pone a
trabajar en la construcción porque
también aparejador pero sigue creando
porque decides no exponer unas cosas de
la vida
muchas veces pensamos que podemos
organizar los dos pero al final no los
controlamos es decir subió la tentativa
a una exposición en europa
salí por ella y nada de tomar la
decisión de quedarme a vivir aquí en
europa
lo han hecho muchos artistas cubanos
antes de wilfredo lam a mí la verdad es
que todos han viajado han buscado mundo
han visto realmente algo fuera de la tea
y eso fue creo que me tocó a mí y fundé
mi familia y a partir de ahí es y los
cambios normales y como todo emigrante
es decir me he tenido que reinventar y
esa es la razón por la cual también de
alguna forma salí del proceso de lo que
es
la
presentación
el reconocimiento que te apoya la
inclusión la pérdida en ese aspecto con
sal y de cuba pero no siguió siguió
creando en sin exponer pero siguió en
ese proceso de creación hasta que bueno
hay un reencuentro con ross mi portero
porque se conocen desde la infancia pero
se perdieron de vista durante durante
mucho tiempo
porter que ha hecho carrera como
comisario de exposiciones de arte
contemporáneo en francia y en otros
lugares del mundo y fue un reencuentro
en 2014 en madrid lo que hizo que
carracedo volviera un poco pues a la
escena pública y fue gracias a usted
cuéntenos si fue ahora será mi forma
bien gracias a la galerista evalúa
yo fui a madrid a ver otros artistas
me encomendó hacer una visita y
coincidió que nos vimos con carracedo
nos fueron que fue hace años que no nos
habíamos y que arrasó estaba trabajando
en ese periodo en un restaurant estaba
trabajando de mesero
un mozo de café cómo se dicen en españa
y llegó y como siempre empezamos a
conversar a reírnos y saca un boludo de
dibujos y me dice mira mira estos
dibujos que estaba haciendo últimamente
es increíble porque me pasó horas en el
metro y le da un nervio increíble al
dibujo el movimiento del metro me enseñó
a que ellos seguimos conversando estuvo
simpático y me ofreció dos o tres
dibujos eso yo lo metí en mi carpeta de
papeles y dos o tres días después en una
reunión con con robert valor de la
galería valva estamos en buró
conversando yo saco mis papeles y el
mirar los dibujos gratis son y si eso
que es el cuento rápido no es un amigo
mío excelente pintor está en españa pero
no he querido exponer más
y nada me ofreció no por eso si gustan
súper interesantes que trabajan con él
es que ponerlo voy a verlo regresa revés
e iba a verlo conversa a veces podemos
hacer a conjuntos bueno y a partir de
ahí vuelve a exponernos a raíz de se
prepara una serie fue la primera
exposición con una galería de fuerte
aquí en parís de carracedo
y prepara una serie inspirada en este
encuentro un poco porque si se nos
dibuja una serie de dibujos con fondos
de café
en la galería evalúa está situada en la
rueda es el que hace esquina con la
paleta que es un lugar emblemático de
los pintores este y se montó y consiguió
una performance en la que reservé
durante una media hora fue quien sirvió
el café y le entregaba un dibujo
original a cada cliente entonces por
sorpresa integrando sus dos facetas de
ese momento
bueno pues ahí a partir de ahí ya vuelve
a exponer en parís la habana nueva york
también creo en la habana no los pusimos
en
en unesco se expuso en el pared de kabul
en italia durante altísimas se expuso en
nueva york y se puso también en parís en
la en la batería en la quería evaluar
bueno pues ahora vuelve a parís con esta
exposición con su cosmogonía que es el
fruto de cinco años de colaboración con
bogeys genoma que es un diseñador de
moda imprescindible para entender un
poco los cambios que hubo en el código
vestimentario a partir de los años 60
que cambió
su faceta de diseñador por el de
fotógrafo gran fotógrafo que ha
fotografiado a estrellas tanto de la
literatura de la música como del cine
del siglo 20 en 24 fotos de renomar que
han sido impresas en lienzo e
intervenidas por usted como ha sido este
el proceso de creación bueno ha sido un
proceso realmente que me sorprendió
desde el principio es decir me hubiera
gustado que hubiera contado es que fue
el artífice que como comisario y el arma
realmente de que se diera la fusión no
entre mauricio porque bueno y conocí
amauris
agobio no sé todavía no me ha explicado
que podía salir bien esto es lo que me
conoce a mí que tengo un carácter un
poco retraído y incluso que me voy hacia
hacia mí se me mundo y de hecho por eso
alguna de las explicaciones que intentó
buscar yo al ostracismo no de esos casi
15 años que estuve en españa sin exponer
pero bueno seguir trabajando
en esa
se dio una ocasión de que mauricio es
poner en la habana en medio de una
comisaría que había hecho el roaming y
de pronto me dices qué te parece si mira
las fotos de renault a ver qué te parece
digo déjame a verlas ya mí me atraparon
muchísimos dos una nadadora que tiene
inmediatamente viese nada ahora inmersa
no en el medio acuático sino en el
universo vegetal que es algo recurrente
que está dentro de mi obra y me parece
que es interesante tú crees que me lo
pudieran imprimir así con el fondo
blanco y incluso hizo un espejo sin
invertida nada ahora hicimos un díptico
que está ahí ahora mismo la exposición
con mo'nique y a partir de ahí comenzó
el proyecto que ocurre que
las colaboraciones no pueden ser desde
mi punto de vista forzosas tiene que
fluir tiene la conexión tiene que haber
una conexión tiene que haber un fluir y
yo creo que se dio ahí
cuando ocurrió ese primer es ese primer
comienzo y ahí bueno pues se
seleccionaron 24 obras y de las cuales
fui poco a poco
de hecho intentando no no de formar de
alguna forma los códigos de ron o más
pero en la medida que se fueron
surgiendo fui pidiendo que me dejaran y
surgieron obras que donde la propia
deformidad o ocultación de partes de la
propia de los propios textos de rne o
más
dieron un resultado mucho más
interesante y yo creo que han despertado
un universo
de sorpresa porque yo mismo me lo
esperaba y la verdad he terminado con
muchísimas
gratitud por el hecho de tener la
oportunidad de poder colaborar con una
persona tan célebre como el decir yo
considero que es una persona
efectivamente como la trabaja de decir
es decir que has registrado momentos muy
importantes y personalidades muy
importantes en la cultura del siglo 20 y
21 y no solamente eso sino es que ha
tenido un ojo muy muy fino yo digo
incluso tiene una gran sencillez y es
una habilidad muy grande que los buenos
fotógrafos de captar momentos especiales
es con una síntesis muy interesante
estos en ese aspecto me parece muy
interesante la obra del renombrado me he
buscado en el diccionario que quiere
decir exactamente con su como bonnie a
que es el título que lleva la muestra y
dice es una narración mitológica sobre
la cual se pretende establecer el origen
del mundo el ser humano y el universo
cuál es la narración ros mín que propone
en carracedo y retoma
el título de la exposición vino a partir
de una sugerencia precisamente de román
es un reto decías con respecto a su
trabajo fotográfico
pero norma de una persona que se dice tú
ya tú cómo se dicen frases tuya tú me
interesa todo ha hecho de todo y como
artista es muy tranquilo y con su
aparato de fotos va a todas partes y
tira foto y forty forty forty foto
de tantas fotos que te la va a crear un
universo una manera de interpretar una
visión muy propia de su vida nuestra
vida y de cierto modo cuando ves la
perspectiva de todas las fotos ya que
eso es un universo
en el caso de cárcel
es lo mismo carracedo
cuando entra con su trabajo
en las obras que realiza el muestra su
universo propio
yo pienso que al final la idea de esta
fusión crear
no encuentro una nueva realización queda
lo que se llama cosmogonía el alter ego
de carracedo es el astronauta
acompañado siempre de elementos
arquitectónicos como la torre y de la
naturaleza con los paisajes de fondo y a
veces con la hibridación de figuras y en
el caso del noma por ejemplo en los
últimos dos años se ha centrado mucho en
el tema de un pescado que le llama
cristóbal y lo considera su 'alter ego'
es un pescado que le toman fotos a todas
partes donde va durante 23 años a
persona que se mueve muchísimo en asia
europa estados unidos y
de cierto modo es ese pescado en las
fotos la situación es que en las tomas
muestra una crítica al consumismo y el
uso abusivo del plástico al problema que
tiene el planeta
y el debate actual con respecto a la
sostenibilidad un debate que igualmente
carracedo toca su obra desde hace muchos
años justamente que no es un efecto de
moda lleva trabajando con esa conciencia
planetaria desde desde hace tales
décadas y si habla del pez como alter
ego de renomar usted tiene un alter ego
que es el astronauta y que aparecen
muchas de sus obras qué quiere decir el
astronauta es una metáfora muy simple
intento buscar cosas sencillas porque
dentro del arte de una cosa que sí me
interesa me interesa comunicar aunque
nosotros no somos literatos es decir le
escritores describiendo cosas
específicas pero si me por empresa me
gusta narrar la historia me gusta
conectar editar contenidos y el
astronauta es un poco el símil de alguna
forma de lo que somos nosotros los
considero que cada uno de nosotros es
una es una visión muy personal somos
viajeros
entonces cuando intenté buscar ese
personaje o diseñar ese personaje dije
bueno qué de qué forma está vestido ese
viajero pues opuestas vestidos de
viajeros y me di cuenta que el traje que
más lejos ha llegado aunque mejor se ha
preparado para las inclemencias más
hostiles es el del astronauta de hecho
también tiene que ver como muy como
infancia es decir cuando tuve nueve años
la profesora mía de la de la primaria me
preguntó siempre la pregunta típica de
usted que crece cuando sea mayor y yo le
dije cosmonauta pero eso fue un año
antes que subiera a nado tamayo el
primer cosmonauta juzgar y me robó la
plaza entonces me enfadé muchísimo con
el metro está madero que me robó pero
bueno ya tenía nueve años es decir no
podría competir con ellos y entonces
desde ese entonces quizás es ese
personaje siempre me gusta me gusta
mucho también el tema de las estrellas
yo creo que lo mejor podría haber
estudiado astros astronomía que nosotros
los días y entonces como nautas un poco
eso es el símil de la de lo que somos
como viajeros
bueno pues les deseo que sigan viajando
por mucho tiempo ya no nos queda tiempo
en este programa y les deseo que les
vaya muy bien en esta exposición en el
espacio niemeyer de parís de esa
exhibición cosmogonía que va a estar
creó todo el mes de octubre verdad
bastante natural entidad 27
bueno pues muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que nos pueden seguir por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en france24 punto com
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]